It never reached the same heights as the likes
of "Star Trek" and "Star Wars," but "Stargate"
still managed to carve out a place for itself
in the sci-fi genre. Where is the cast today,
and how much have they changed over
the decades? Let's take a look.
Playing the part of hyper-intelligent
Egyptologist Dr. Daniel Jackson,
James Spader originated the role that was
taken up by Michael Shanks on "Stargate
SG-1". It's Spader's character that
unlocks the secrets of the Stargate,
deciphering some hieroglyphics that turn out to be
coordinates based on the constellations. He agrees
to accompany Kurt Russell's Colonel Jack O'Neill
and his men through the wormhole he helped open,
stepping onto an arid planet ruled by the
Egyptian god Ra, who is actually an ancient alien.
Spader broke out almost a decade before
"Stargate," putting in a scene-stealing
performance as elitist bully Steff in John
Hughes' classic "Pretty in Pink." He was in
danger of being typecast as a silver-spoon brat
in the '80s, but he proved his versatility the
following decade. After "Stargate," Spader starred
in David Cronenberg's kinky thriller "Crash," and,
more recently, he voiced the titular
villain in "Avengers: Age of Ultron."
Nowadays, he's best known for his TV work,
having played Raymond "Red" Reddington on
NBC's "The Blacklist" since 2013. The show got
delayed during the coronavirus pandemic in 2020,
which allowed him to spend some
quality time with his youngest son.
"We'd go out and line up beer cans
on the big rock out on the far end of the
garden and shoot at them with BB guns."
The character Ra has been featured in numerous
pieces of "Stargate" media over the years.
The androgynous Egyptian god showed up in episodes
of "Stargate SG-1" and "Stargate Origins,"
and also played a part in
direct-to-DVD movie "Stargate:
Continuum." Ra's most iconic appearance
is in the first "Stargate" movie, however,
and that's largely down to the mesmerizing
Jaye Davidson, a dressmaker who got close to
tasting Oscar glory after being spotted
by a film scout in a bar one night.
Despite not being an actor by trade, Davidson
was cast as the transgender character Dil in
1992's "The Crying Game" two years before
his involvement in "Stargate". The film was
nominated for Best Picture the following year,
and Davidson was up for Best Supporting Actor.
The Oscar buzz made Davidson an overnight star,
and the pressure quickly became too much for him.
He decided to quit acting, but when the part of
Ra came along and the studio agreed to pay him a
million dollars, he gave it another go. Davidson
turned in yet another terrific performance as Ra
in what would be his last major appearance.
After appearing in the movie "Jiggery Pokery",
he promptly returned to his first love: fashion.
Indian-American character actor Erick Avari has
one of those faces that you've definitely seen
before, though you're not entirely sure where.
In "Stargate," he plays village elder Kasuf,
who welcomes the explorers warmly when they
arrive. He's particularly fond of James Spader's
Dr. Jackson, who unknowingly agrees to take his
daughter's hand in marriage. Avari is one of the
few who went on to reprise his "Stargate" role,
playing Kasuf in three seasons of "Stargate SG-1".
Avari stuck with "Stargate" director Roland
Emmerich after making his debut as Kasuf,
following him onto his next big sci-fi epic,
"Independence Day," in which he popped up briefly
as a scientist. He landed a far more substantial
role in the Brendan Fraser-led action adventure
"The Mummy" a few years later, appearing as Dr.
Terrence Bey, curator of the Cairo Museum of
Antiquities and boss of Rachel Weisz's character
Evelyn Carnahan. He also played an ill-fated
human in Tim Burton's "Planet of the Apes,"
a lawyer in Adam Sandler comedy "Mr. Deeds,"
and a hot dog cart vendor in Richard Gere's
"Hachi: A Dog's Tale," among many other roles.
Video game fans will no doubt recognize
Avari's distinctive tones from 2014's "Destiny"
and 2017's "Destiny 2," in which he voiced
Master Rahool. In his most recent role,
he played mysterious biblical
figure Nicodemus in "The Chosen,"
a crowdfunded TV series about
the life of Jesus Christ.
Kasuf's daughter Sha'uri — the one who gets
offered up to Dr. Daniel Jackson — was played by
Israeli actor Mili Avital. The unlikely pair fall
for each other as they battle Ra, and when his
rule comes to an end, Jackson opts to stay behind
on the newly liberated planet. If you cut out the
part where Sha'uri is basically given away as a
gift, it's a fairytale ending done sci-fi style.
Avital was a newcomer in Hollywood
when she scored her "Stargate" role.
It was just her third appearance on the
big screen, and, despite the mixed reviews,
the film opened doors for her. She worked
tirelessly in the latter part of the 1990s,
appearing in no less than nine movies between
1995 and 2000. Her most notable credits from
the time include the Jim Jarmusch Western "Dead
Man," in which she played a former sex worker,
and the rom-com "Kissing a Fool," in which she has
to choose between David Schwimmer and Jason Lee.
She spent time in Morocco and Turkey working
on ABC's lavish miniseries "Arabian Nights,"
then returned to Israel to continue her career at
home. She still pops up on American screens every
now and again, however, most recently in a 2015
episode of "Law & Order: Special Victims Unit."
Alexis Cruz plays Skaara, Kasuf's son. He is
heavily involved in the uprising against Ra,
but his most memorable scenes are the ones
shared with Kurt Russell's Captain O'Neill,
who is still grieving the loss of his
child when we enter the "Stargate" story.
Spending time with Skaara — who, in
turn, sees the captain as something
of a father figure — helps him do
some healing while on the mission.
Cruz made his movie debut in 1987's "The Pick-up
Artist," a rom-com starring Robert Downey Jr. and
Molly Ringwald. "Stargate" was the biggest
opportunity of his then-fledgling career,
and his time in the franchise remains the
thing he's best known for. He has, however,
proven himself to be a versatile performer over
the years. He's appeared in movies like "Why Do
Fools Fall in Love" and Sam Raimi's "Drag Me
to Hell," and he's plied his trade on a number
of big TV shows, including "ER" and "American
Family." He's been busy in recent years, both in
his personal and professional life — he welcomed a
son in 2019, returned to TV in an episode of Anna
Kendrick's HBO series "Love Life" in 2020, and,
in 2021, he guest starred on CBS procedural "FBI."
Benin born model and actor Djimon
Hounsou is pretty well-known these days,
but back when he appeared as Ra's guard Horus
in "Stargate," he was still relatively unknown.
He began his career in music videos, acting
in Tina Turner's "I Don't Wanna Lose You,"
En Vogue's "Hold On," and Janet Jackson's
"Love Will Never Do (Without You)."
"Stargate" was his first feature film, and
while it wasn't the one that made him a star,
Hounsou didn't have to wait very long
afterwards to break into the mainstream.
The West African newcomer was in three films
in 1997, one of which earned him a Golden Globe
nod. He didn't get nominated for an Oscar for
his turn as slave revolt leader Joseph Cinque
in Steven Spielberg's "Amistad," but
the historical drama put him firmly on
Hollywood's radar. Hounsou would receive
his arguably overdue recognition from the
Academy for later appearances in 2002's
"In America" and 2006's "Blood Diamond,"
being considered in the Best Supporting
Actor category for both pictures.
"You are a good boy, who loves soccer and school."
In recent years, Hounsou has become a regular
in the superhero genre, working on numerous
Marvel projects. After voicing T'Challa in
the animated "Black Panther" miniseries,
he appeared as Korath in "Guardians of the Galaxy"
and "Captain Marvel," a role he'll reprise in the
animated Disney+ series "What If...?" He's
got some DC characters on his resume, too.
Hounsou played Midnight in "Constantine," King
Ricou in "Aquaman," and the Wizard in "Shazam!"
Character actor Leon Rippy played the role of
commanding officer Lieutenant General W. O. West,
the man in charge when Dr. Jackson discovers
how to operate the ancient Stargate portal.
The South Carolina native was already a
favorite of Emmerich's when the filmmaker
started casting for "Stargate," having appeared
in his previous films "Moon 44" and "Universal
Soldier." He would go on to appear in three
more of Emmerich's movies: "The Patriot,"
"The Thirteenth Floor", and the wacky monster
horror extravaganza "Eight Legged Freaks".
Rippy has only appeared in a handful of
movies since then, the most notable being
Gore Verbinski's "The Lone Ranger". He is better
known for his TV work today, having recurred on
shows like "Deadwood," "Saving Grace", and the
Stephen King adaptation "Under the Dome." He
reunited with "Stargate" co-star James Spader when
he joined the cast of "The Blacklist" in 2016,
and, in a more recent credit, reprised his
"Deadwood" role in a TV movie of the same name.
He would get famous playing the idiotic Harry
Solomon on "3rd Rock from the Sun," but funnyman
French Stewart had a pivotal role in "Stargate"
before he was a sitcom star. The actor made his
feature film debut in Roland Emmerich's sci-fi
adventure, playing Lieutenant Ferretti. He's left
in charge of the second unit when the soldiers
arrive, though he's forced to retreat into the
temple of Ra during a massive sandstorm, which,
of course, turns out to be a big mistake. The men
under Ferretti's command are taken down by Ra's
guards one by one, before he himself is captured.
Stewart made his debut as Harry Solomon
on "3rd Rock from the Sun" in 1996
and would remain on the show until it wrapped in
2001. He went on to become a dependable TV actor,
appearing in the likes of "That '70s Show,"
"Ally McBeal," "Bones," "MadTV," "Community,"
and even "Stargate Universe," in which he
played a new character, Dr. Andrew Covel.
He went on to play Principal Cameron on ABC's
"The Middle," but in recent years he's become
known for the CBS sitcom "Mom," appearing as
Chef Rudy in dozens of episodes. He's also
in Michael Lembeck's retirement home comedy
"Queen Bees," scheduled for release in 2021.
It wouldn't be sci-fi without some members of the
exploration party being picked off by the enemy,
and that was the fate of Derek Webster's
Lieutenant Brown in "Stargate."
He's with Jackson and O'Neill when
they make contact with the locals,
and he even gets to sample some local food
before he's killed by one of Ra's guards.
Webster made his debut playing a bodyguard in
1981's "Enter the Ninja," a low-budget martial
arts flick. He then appeared in "Star Trek: The
Next Generation" a year or so before "Stargate,"
showing up in a 1993 episode as Lieutenant
Sanders. He became a go-to character actor
for Roland Emmerich after "Stargate,"
joining him on "Independence Day" to
play the pilot of the helicopter that gets
blown up during Operation Welcome Wagon,
mankind's ill-fated attempt at communicating with
the alien invaders. After this role, he joined up
with Emmerich again for "Godzilla" in which he
captains the nuclear-powered submarine USS Utah.
He established himself as a
solid TV actor in the 2000s
with roles in the likes of "Nip/Tuck," and
"CSI: Miami," and he's still active today.
Webster played DA Jackson Holt on "Ray
Donovan" between 2016 and 2017, and in
2020 he returned to the "Star Trek" franchise
as a Romulan guard in "Star Trek: Picard."
As Colonel Jack O'Neill's right hand man,
John Diehl's Lieutenant Kawalsky helps keep
the team together when they are ambushed
by Ra's guards and taken captive aboard
his ship. Diehl was an experienced character
actor long before he appeared in "Stargate,"
having established himself in the early 1980s.
He actually shared the screen with Kurt Russell
in his second movie appearance, playing
a punk in John Carpenter's "Escape From
New York." He went on to recur as Detective
Larry Zito on "Miami Vice" and appear in Joel
Schumacher's "The Client" before Roland
Emmerich cast him in his sci-fi epic.
Diehl has been seen in numerous
feature films since "Stargate,"
usually in a smaller or supporting role.
He's worked on everything from "Jurassic
Park III" to Michael Bay's "Pearl Harbor".
In recent years, he's taken to old-guy roles,
growing out his grey beard for the likes
of the ranch-set Western "Out of the Wild",
in which he played an alcoholic cowboy looking
for redemption. His other notable television
credits include "Snowfall", "Castlerock",
and "The Shield", among many others.
The actor that plays the lead role of Colonel
Jack O'Neill in "Stargate" really needs no
introduction. Massachusetts native Kurt
Russell began his career as a child actor,
signing a contract with Disney after impressing
with his performance in 1966's "Follow Me, Boys!"
Walt Disney reportedly dealt with the contract
personally and would remain a big fan of the
young star up until Disney's death. He was already
well known when he took on the role of special ops
expert Jack O'Neill years later, having fronted
the likes of John Carpenter's "Escape From
New York," "Big Trouble in Little China," and
"Tombstone," in which he portrayed Wyatt Earp.
After "Stargate", Russell continued to establish
himself as one of Hollywood's most reliable
actors. He experienced what the Toronto Sun
described as, quote, "a spectacular career
revival" following his turn as a brutal bounty
hunter in Quentin Tarantino's "The Hateful Eight"
in 2015. He subsequently appeared in a number
of big films, most notably "Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol. 2" in which he played Star-Lord's
villainous father Ego the Living Planet. More
recently, Russell has starred as Santa Claus in
Netflix's popular "Christmas Chronicles" movies,
and he reunited with Tarantino for
"Once Upon a Time... In Hollywood,"
playing stunt coordinator Randy Miller.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.